真正两个人婚姻要经营的比较好的话，
一定是这两个人都是独立的灵魂，
在精神上是脱离原生家庭的，
两个人之间的矛盾是自己可以去调解的，
而不是说还要听爸爸妈妈在掺和你们两口子之间的矛盾，
你们两口子间的经济关系，
包括以后的孩子的教育关系，
如果双方的家长任何一方过度参与的话，
那基本上都得散伙。
今年我25岁了，
我和男朋友谈了五年了，
明年后年可能会结婚，
他24，
由于他考工作，
他比我工作晚两年，
现在呢，
他在市区呢找到了一个编外的老师，
已经工作两个月了，
我目前呢，
有一份国企的工作，
在郊区，
我俩通勤的距离离得比较近，
工作地点离得比较近，
通勤距离呢有20分钟，
婚房买的是在郊区，
婚房离我们两个通勤距离都是40分钟，
我的国企的工作离我妈妈家大概是一个多小时，
因为我现在未婚，
所以是跟爸爸妈妈住在一起，
家里希望我换一个可以离你们家近的地方。
我男朋友跟我商量，
他现在虽然不稳定，
但是他们学校上课比较早，
所以就希望我可以在他们学校附近租一个房子，
结婚的时候把婚房租出去。
现在我有两个问题，
一个就是工作到底是应该离娘家近还是？
就是未来老公近，
还有一个问题，
到底要不要答应男朋友结婚，
先跟他租几年的房子，
等工作稳定了以后再考虑换房子的事情。
我觉得啊，
这个事儿不是近和远的问题，
姑娘是你在哪里工作，
你觉得很开心，
很有价值感，
觉得很受尊重，
这个才是关键，
而不是说离你娘家近，
离老公近，
不是工作，
因为占我们人生很大的一个时间的比例了，
一定是工作单位，
你感觉在哪个工作单位分别也挺好的，
工作起来挺开心的，
情绪不用那么多的压在你身上的各种大山什么的，
你在哪里工作，
你自己觉得得心应手就在哪里工作，
因为我找的这份国企的工作，
我还没有入职，
我现在正在考虑距离远近的问题，
就只有这一个问题，
工作内容还有什么的，
包括薪资待遇我都比较满意，
唯独家里觉得我这个工作离家太远了，
但是我又那就去工作，
因为我觉得啊，
我说这话可能又得罪很多父母了，
有的父母他可能是觉得你离家近，
他看你方便一点儿怎么地的，
但有的父母是觉得离家近他好用你是吧？
我感觉这事儿应该是，
反正我是这种心态，
我现在也是为人父母了，
我是这种心态，
孩子怎么开心怎么来，
孩子怎么幸福怎么来，
孩子怎么觉得有价值怎来，
所以就是我离娘家，
比如说一个半小时的距离，
工作可能要跑。
两三年之后我爸结婚了，
可能会换房子，
你家自己租个房子住呗，
租个小间住着呗，
我是那种没有什么自理能力的人，
也不会做饭，
一直是家里我妈妈照顾我，
那我你你没有自理能力，
那怎么的，
结婚了之后就牵一个奴隶伺候你呗，
不是结婚也其实主要是吃饭的问题，
结婚以后的话，
基本上就是我男朋友做饭，
我洗碗，
这样子，
剩下的可能也是需要磨合，
要么两个人都是那种家里照顾了很久的那种，
他比我自己能力强很多，
因问其实我是八宝女，
确实我感觉我有点嗯，
所以在工作这方面的话，
离娘家远一点其实是无所谓的，
等结婚以后再换房子，
这个就可以是吗？
我觉得啊，
现在找工作挺难的，
姑娘找工作真的挺难的，
你找到一个工作，
你先好好干着啊，
目前我有两个选择，
一个就是进这家国企，
另一个就是再等一等，
看看有没有其他的机会再进国企，
因为这边家里也是在只能帮我努力，
所以家里希望我再等等，
但是我自己比较着急嘛，
因为元旦可能会订婚，
如果没有工作的话，
就可能会往后拖结婚的事儿，
还有我每天自己在家里也没有收入，
自己做了一个。
一直每天很焦虑，
因为我是从五六月份就开始在等这个事情，
这咋说呢？
你要觉得你跟你父母在一起更开心，
那你就听你父母的，
你要是觉得你想要自己独立，
想要自己过小日子，
我跟你讲，
像你的这种情况，
如果你离父母非常近，
而你的父母又插手你的婚姻的话，
以后婚姻关系是很难相处的，
以后跟老公的关系非常难相处，
我明白了，
罗飞姐，
丽姐跟你分享我自己的这种感受，
真正两个人婚姻要经营的比较好的话，
一定是这两个人都是独立的灵魂，
两个人都脱离了原生家庭，
在精神上是脱离原生家庭的，
两个人之间的矛盾是自己可以去调解的，
而不是说还要听爸爸妈妈在掺和你们两口子之间的矛盾，
你们两口子间的经济关系，
包括以后的孩子的教育关系，
如果双方的家长任何一方过度参与的话，
那基本上都得散伙。
我不知道直播间有多少人经历过这样的事情，
一定是你们两个人都是成熟的、
独立的，
自己能处理问题的自己，
能解决纠纷的自己能决定自己人生方向的，
自己能够给自己的人生做很好的计划和规划的杨总在一起才有可能。
我明白了。
龙妃姐，
我还有一个问题，
就是未来我们两个如果换房子的话，
到底要不要考虑离婆家或者娘家任何一家近？
觉得是方便带孩子，
你比如说两个人下班都晚，
没有时间做饭的话，
可以回去送饭什么的，
要不等你有了孩子或者怀了孕你再来问，
我现在都太远了，
因为你还不知道婆婆是啥性格呢，
不知道跟婆婆相处的好不好呢，
我们俩相处五年了，
一直有跟我的未来的婆婆一直在相处，
她是那种就是活的很潇洒的那种人，
她的孩子就是奶奶他的，
她也跟我承诺，
如果我们以后有孩子的话，
他也会给我去看孩子，
去支付孩子的费用，
我们可以不怎么看孩子，
但是呢，
可能周六日销毁，
去看孩子，
看看姑娘，
你现在想的太简单了，
我告诉你哦，
女人在怀孕和生产这个过程当中的话，
会产生大量的各种各样的激素，
会控制你的人生，
打开一个程序，
谁带孩子你都不放心，
基本上都是这样的，
所以说你妈妈也好，
你婆婆也好，
你得观察他俩，
他俩如果都想带孩子的话，
他俩还得竞争上岗，
谁带孩子更科学，
谁带孩子更健康。
我是家里的二胎，
我妈妈生我生的比较晚，
所以她是不愿意带孩子的，
她带出来的孩子也是我哥哥，
也是那种自理能力比较弱的人，
所以我没有打算来。
我的意思是你婆婆现在说的这个事儿真到，
结了婚真到，
你生了孩子真到。
开始带孩子，
我跟你说两码事儿，
等到时候相处了之后再说好的，
我工作的事儿就不要再等了，
先不要考虑工作距离的问题，
觉得其他的方面都不错就入职就好了，
是吗？
因为你这份工作是凭你自己本事找的，
没错吧，
就是是家里给我找的，
家里面给你找了一个工作，
又让你别去这个工作，
又说再给你找一个工作，
是这样吗？
对，
后面再找的话，
可能要再等一等，
可能等三五个月，
那人家这个工作会等你三五个月吗？
也是需要看就需不需要招人，
所以我也是需要家里再帮我找一找，
比如说这个时间单位需要人了，
才需要，
大概确定了，
应该就是三个月或者四个月或者五个月吧，
那我问你，
你喜欢跟你爸妈生活在一起吗？
结婚，
那你就听你爸妈的吧，
但是我自己又特别着急，
因为我已经等了半年了，
才有这么一个不合适的，
那你不是喜欢待在家里吗？
你为什么着急呢？
那我着急是因为我觉得我空窗太久的话，
以后要是自己找工作的话，
肯定就会相当于更难了，
再加上我找这个兼职一个月挣3000块钱，
感觉挣的太少了，
再多等半年的话，
就少挣半年的钱，
我真的咱俩可能不在一个频道上，
我确实没有过这么好的原生家庭啊，
没有我跟爸妈这么亲密的关。
所以呢，
我确实也很难感受到你的那个困境，
你既然在家待的好好的，
那就很么了呗，
有什么大不了的呢？
因为我这两年我是肯定会结婚的，
所以我就在想，
结了婚以后，
那这个工作可能就会离得近一点，
我就想去这个工作，
但是家里觉得国企有点小，
再加上离得远，
所以就让我再等等，
所以我在跟家里处于僵持的状态，
要不你看看评论区，
看有没有跟你原生家庭差不多的，
跟爸妈关系也挺好的，
跟爸妈眷恋比较深的人，
他们会怎么选，
好不好好的好，
那就这样啊，
谢谢罗菲姐，
刚刚我我也没有说是没被气笑了或者干嘛的，
确实是人和人之间是有壁垒的，
因为我每个人看到的世界是不一样的嘛，
像我的话，
其实我很难想象每天跟父母在一起，
每天跟父母住一起，
每天跟父母吃饭，
完了之后，
我老公可能将来也得每周都回来跟我父母吃饭，
我很难想象这个场景，
确实是没啥可聊的，
我跟父母见面3分钟事儿就聊完了，
接下来就没啥可聊的事儿了，
确实是每个人的这种人生经历不一样，
你让我想象一下，
说哎呀，
以后我老公还得每周都得陪着我跟我爸妈在一块儿吃饭或者干嘛的，
我会觉得我老公应该是很可怜他，
也不排除说老公跟他爸妈关系也挺好啊，
也有这个缘分是吧，
也挺好，
也不排除这种可能性，
我觉得。
事儿呢，
就比如说可能她婆婆给她带孩子，
她自己也是个孩子，
她挺放心，
能让婆婆带也有这种可能性，
但是我以我自己的亲身体验来看的话，
刚开始的孩子谁在我都不放心，
只有我自己看着，
我自己像一个老鹰一样的看着他，
我才放心啊。
后来问的是雅，
经过长时间的观察，
长时间盯着监控器，
长时间的观察，
我才放心给月儿嫂带。
记得点赞关注哦。